we want to socialize and normalize sex
in the real world
make it easier for everyone to talk
about to promote consent
communication good sexual values and
good sexual behavior
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great and thrilled to be here
michael
i'm i'm thrilled to have you here are
you calling from london right now
um no i live in new york where i've
lived for the past um
23 years so i'm in my new york apartment
i i i the last i remember was from 23
years ago so i just haven't been updated
but
thank you for the clarification cindy i
i love the shirt you're very wearing
because we are going to talk today about
make love not
porn uh cindy i'm proud to say that i'm
talking to somebody who started
a a website that is centered around sex
knowledge and pro-sex pro-knowledge you
launched
your movement back in 2009 on the ted
stage which is a huge honor and i'd love
to hear about that experience
but give me a little bit of a random
about your life and how do you
get to start a you know a pro
sex knowledge website sure so the answer
is by complete
accident michael i never set out to do
what i now find myself doing
um it came about through my direct
personal experience dating younger men
and realizing um that i was experiencing
what happens when
two things converge and i stress the
dual convergence because most people
think it's only one thing
i realized i was experiencing what
happens when today's
total freedom of access to hardcore porn
online
meets our society's equally total
reluctance
to talk openly and honestly about sex
it's when those two things converge porn
becomes sex education by default in not
a good way
and so i decided to do something about
this and 11 years ago
um i put up a no money a tiny clunky
website at makelovenotporn.com that in
its original iteration was just words
the construct was porn world versus real
world launched at ted as you mentioned
became the only ted speaker to say the
words come on my face on the ted stage
six times the succession the talk went
viral as a result
and it drove this extraordinary global
response to my tiny website
that i had never anticipated thousands
of people wrote to me from every country
in the world
young and old male and female straight
and gay and so i felt i had a
responsibility
to take make love not porn forwards in a
way that would make it much more
far-reaching
helpful and effective and so given that
um our mission is as we mentioned
our tagline says we are pro sex pro porn
pro knowing the difference and so
i turned make love not porn into the
world's first and only
user generated human curated social
sex video sharing platform so
we are pioneering a whole new category
on the internet
that never before existed social sets
we're like what facebook would be if it
allowed you to socially
sexually self-express which obviously
doesn't because
we want to socialize and normalize sex
in the real world
make it easier for everyone to talk
about to promote consent
communication good sexual values and
good sexual behavior
so we call ourselves the social sex
revolution
so we're talking about you know you
mentioned
this idea of being good and bad and i
think that one of the things that
you know i've come to to realize and i
don't think that it should have been a
self-realization i think
it should be pretty common understanding
and then there is no one said way of
being good in bed right there's no
right or wrong way to have sex it's
about the communication it's about
whether you're enjoying your partner and
the partner is enjoying you
and it's that communication that is the
derivative of that right
you can't replicate what you do with one
partner with another partner
because it's a different relationship no
no exactly
michael but also being good in bed
starts further back than that
so um when i say make love not quons
missions is very simple thing
make it easy to talk about sex because
we don't do that currently people don't
get how
massively society transformative that
would be
and here's what i mean i decide to make
love not porn around my own beliefs and
philosophies
one of which is that everything in life
starts with you and your values
so i regularly ask people this question
what are your sexual values
and nobody can ever answer me because
we're not taught to think like that
right our parents bring us up to have
good manners
a work ethic sense of responsibility
accountability
nobody ever brings us up to behave
well in bed right but they should
because in bed values like empathy
sensitivity generosity
kindness honesty respect are as
important
as those values are in every other area
of our lives
where we're actively taught to exercise
them so here's my
world view of what the world will be
like
when make love not porn achieves its
mission at scale
parents will bring their children up
openly to have
good sexual values and good sexual
behavior the same way they currently
bring kids up to have good vibes and
behave in every other area of life
we will therefore cease to bring up
rapists
because the only way that you end rape
culture
is by embedding in society and openly
talked about promoted and very
importantly aspired to
gold standard of what constitutes good
sexual values and good sexual behavior
when we do that we also end me too
we end sexual harassment abuse violence
all
areas where the perpetrators currently
rely on the fact that we do not talk
about sex
to ensure victims never speak up never
go to authorities never tell anybody
when we end that we massively empower
women and girls worldwide
when we do that we create a far happy
world for everybody including men
and when we do that we are one step
closer to world peace
i talk about make love not porn as my
attempt to bring about world peace
and i'm not joking cindy uh
i i've done more than 300 episodes of
this and this is one of the most
awesome and inspiring things that i've
heard eh
talk to me a little bit about about this
viewpoint that you have
you're tying this now you know it
started out from you know sex education
to actually talking about
you know rape rape and harassment and
the metoo movement go a little bit
deeper with me how are these things
are we moving actually towards that um
so it's very simple
michael because what i designed to make
love not porn to be
is education through demonstration okay
and so what i mean by that is right now
in the ear of me too quite rightly
everybody is talking about consent
everybody is writing about consent there
are lots of thoughtful nuanced
insightful think people out there about
consent here's the problem
nobody knows what consent actually looks
like in bed
the only way you educate people as to
what is
great consensual communicative sex good
sexual values and behavior
is by watching people actually having
that
kind of sex and make love like porn is
the only place on the internet you can
do that
so that's why i call us education
through demonstration
but but but but here's you know this is
fun right the reason why
i designed to make love not porn to be a
video sharing platform
because the number one use case
for youtube globally is how-to videos it
far
outstrips youtube's second biggest use
case which is entertainment
first and foremost people all around the
world go to youtube
to watch how-to videos on how to do
anything and everything
i created make love not porn to be the
global go-to hub
for how-to videos on anything and
everything to do with real-world sex
and so our members write to us and tell
us that you know watching our real world
sex videos
has shown them how to expand their
sexual repertoires
you know do things that they haven't
thought of doing before i mean we get
very moving comments one woman left a
comment she said
this is on one of our lesbian videos all
inclusive you know fully lgbtq
everything
so she left a comment saying i've been
in the closet for 25 years
i've only just come out this video
showed me how to make love to a woman
thank you so much
you know and so you know we are
that crucial source of sex education
that nobody else is providing
which is as i said a window onto how we
all have sex in the real world
operating good sexual values and good
sexual behavior so
cindy tell me a little bit about where
are we moving from here
so here we have cindy galp that is
making an extraordinary effort
to to you know both fix our sex
education and our mindset
but really has far outreaching
implications and and a real big
butterfly effect that i'm already
convinced
but what needs to happen in order for
these things to actually become
mainstream
how do we get our society to actually go
towards the path that you're talking
about
right do you know michael the answer to
that is it's not about society
because ever since i launched make love
not porn 11 years ago
i've had nothing but a universally
positive response from every country in
the world and by the way
we have members and traffic from 184
countries that make love we're fully
um here's the issue i had no idea
when i embarked on this venture that i
and my tiny team would fight an enormous
battle every single day to build it
essentially because every piece of
business infrastructure
any other tech startup takes for granted
we can't
the small print always says no adult
content
and that is all pervasive across the
entire business
in ways that people outside the sphere
don't realize so for example
i can't get funded i'm going to come
back to that i can't get banked
okay it took me four years to find one
bank here in america that would allow me
to open a business bank account make
love.form
our biggest official challenge is
payment okay paypal won't work without
adult content
stripe can't and by the way the families
of striper friends and supporters
that they spoke to their bank who would
not allow them to work with us
every text service i need to use to be
at hosting including encrypting
the terms of service always say no adult
content
we had to build our entire video sharing
platform from scratch
as proprietary technology because
existing streaming services
will not stream at our content i'm so
jealous of friends who
built video starts on top of vimeo quick
easy simple python
even something as simple as finding an
email partner send the membership emails
out with
mailchimp won't work without our content
rejected by six or seventeen we found
sendgrid to word
a couple years ago i needed a contract
lex designer
i put a perfectly standard job
description up on upwork 20 minutes
later upwork took it down
and told us we were not allowed to
advertise jobs on upwork because we're
making
a porn okay now
i'll tell you what overcomes all these
barriers michael
um enough funding totally overcomes
these barriers and and here's my
challenge on the funding front
um my biggest obstacle finding
investments
is the social dynamic that i call fear
of what other people will think
yes because it is never about what the
person i'm talking to thinks
when you understand what we're doing and
why we're doing it to make love nobody
can argue with it
the business case is clear it's always
their fear of what they think other
people will think which operates around
sex unlike any other area
and and here's my a special challenge
i know my investors are out there they
are impossible to find by the usual
means
because sex is the one area where you
cannot tell from the outside
what anybody thinks on the inside the
people who think would probably get it
don't
the people you thought were total
prudence do there is one thing that i
know
anybody willing to fund me all my
investments have in common
okay and that is your willingness to
fund make love not porn is entirely a
function
of your personal sexual journey
it's a function of your personal lens on
sex and sexuality
driven by an experience and there is no
way to research
and target that and so what i do is i
put what i'm doing out there all the
time
because i have to rely on synaptic
connections being made
that will draw those investors to me and
by the way
this does work every so often but it is
a very
long and painful process wow so
how do you actually go about that you
you put yourself out there i mean i'm
coming from the traditional startup
scene where you know you go to a demo
day
you go potentially to y combinator you
present on linkedin you write beautiful
posts and you have lines of investors
that are coming
trying to get a piece of that equity for
your startup yep so um so
you know i've been lobbying y combinator
for years to welcome sex
tech startups they don't okay um
also bear in mind michael that any other
founder looking for investors can at
least
do their research and target they can
great so-and-so has publicly said they
want to invest in my sector clean tech
whatever it is
so-and-so has a portfolio a publicly
viewable that indicates very clearly
that interests are in line with what i'm
doing you know nobody is out there going
bring me sex today okay and so this is
why what i do is
i accept every media interview you know
i accept every podcast
interview request i post all the time
on linkedin on social media on twitter
about what i'm doing the challenges i
face because
as i said i have to rely on my messaging
reaching people
who go wow i want to hear more about
this and by the way
as i said earlier that does in fact work
especially gratifying me
in the past year because just as in the
same way the pandemic has been very good
for our business
you know to uh you know at the end of
we've been seeing 10
a month and month growth our video
submissions rate has tripled okay
everyone's at home in lockdown with
plenty of time in their hands to record
videos make love not porn
um but also i'm very pleased
that i have been getting more and more
investors reaching out
asking to talk about make love not porn
because i am setting out to raise a
round of serious funding this year
and i can tell you that i can see those
barriers breaking down
because what i've had to do michael for
the past eight years since i launched
great love not going dot tv
is i've had to parallel path two things
building my startup
and changing the cultural context around
it
because as i like to say when you have a
truly world-changing startup
you have to change the world to fit it
not the other way around
you know um i don't wait for things to
change i make them change
and i am seeing that change happen which
is very gratifying
i think that's it that's incredible by
the way hey having people record
their own videos at home i think that
you know one of the if porn
in its own word is not you know the most
taboo word i think porn star is probably
is and
i think that every person that hears the
word porn star has a different image of
what they're
of what they're thinking of that person
how do you go about and trying to
encourage people to share their intimate
life which is so scary
so taboo on a social media platform um
so um here's the funny thing michael
people are dying to become make love not
porn stars
not porn stars make love stars so
obviously um when we were building make
love not porn
we had to see the platform with content
pre-launch
so i and my curator spent an entire year
asking our full networks
and complete strangers will you film
yourselves having real world sex threats
and that is terrible i discovered that
99.9 percent of the time the answer is
yes
because you know i would whenever i was
talking about me level point i would
always end the conversation
by asking the question so would you be
interested in contributing content
and i would always ask this question
regardless of whether i personally
thought the person i was talking to
would or wouldn't
and that's how i discovered that most
time the answer was yes
to the extent that i literally had to
force my facial features to stay
immobile because i want to go what
um you know the desire to do this lies a
lot closer to the surface of many more
people you would ever have thought
and given a reason given a social
mission and social values people jump at
the chance
wow i honestly that is that is very
surprising
does that mean that i can be optimistic
going forward that we will
be in a world where you know sharing our
sex life is normal
and is actually encouraged and obviously
by the way you only have to do this
um if you want to but but here's the
fascinating thing michael i'll make love
not porn stars tell us
that socially sharing their real world
sex
has been as transformative for them and
their relationships
as sharing everything else has been for
the world at large
so we have for example many solo videos
okay men and women
and by the way non-binary trans
individuals
who film themselves masturbating and by
the way often for the first time ever
you know the majority of them make love
about porn cells have never filmed
themselves doing anything sexual before
they're doing that they believe in our
social mission they filmed this very
intimate act
and shared it on our platform to be
watched by complete strangers
they tell us that doing that made them
love themselves more
it enhanced their sexual sense of self
their sexual self-esteem
couples tell us doing this transform
their relationship
because when you decide to film
yourselves having sex you have to talk
about it
and when you talk about it doesn't
matter how long you've been together the
conversation goes places it's never ever
gone before
couples write to us and say we thought
we were open doing this just took our
relation to a whole new level
and and here's also um a very
interesting thing michael
so we have a revenue sharing business
model which i designed
to democratize access to income
our members pay to subscribe rent and
stream social sex videos
half that income goes to our
contributors i make love not porn stars
and i'm thrilled to say that during the
pandemic
like everyone else i'll make not porn
cells have lost jobs can't find work
don't you justify yourselves to say
we are thrilled that our make not not
porn stars tell us
that our monthly payouts are helping
them survive the pandemic
again even at our micro bootstrapping
scale
so i want to hit the kind of critical
mass so one day
your social sex video on make love not
porn gets
a million rentals at you know
a dollar a rental and we give you half
that income
that's unbelievable i think that what
you're doing is revolutionary it's
innovative it's
scary uh i'm but i'm leaving here more
optimistic and interested than
than i than i thought it would and
because i think that
you know for anybody that goes on on the
website listens to the talk and
everything i think that we
start to understand what you're doing
we're aligned with it but but hearing
you explain really the the far
outreaching benefits of how that's gonna
have the implications it's gonna have on
our world and our society
our relationships our lives our
happiness levels our comfort levels our
contentness
i think that's inspiring so thank you
for sharing that with me and with my
friends
and colleagues before we leave i have to
ask you for the most important question
which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
the three words i would use to describe
myself are
ask other people i love
my own philosophies michael make love
not porn is education through
demonstration
i'm all about communication through
i don't define myself i believe in being
judged by my actions
and so whenever anybody asks me how i
describe myself i say
ask other people because their judgment
and their observation is what matters
cindy thank you very very much stay safe
and stay healthy
and i'm looking forward to follow the
journey because i think it sounds
it sounds really fascinating and i can't
wait to see where it takes our society
thank you thank you take care bye-bye
really really wonderful thank you cindy
i'll send it to you as soon as we have
it
it was really really great